Hey how's it going bros
my name is
PEEEWDIEPAAH!
And let's find out
why my channel is dying.
(upbeat music)
Google trends, everyone
A wonderful tool
That seems underutilized
*breath*
Have you ever looked on Google Trends?
Has anyone ever done this video before?
Am I the first one?
Oh my god!
Did I just have an original idea?
That's awesome!
[A] Few days ago me and Jack did a video where we looked a little bit into google trends,
but I wanna really dig deeper.
I wanna truly understand why everyone else
is doing so goddamn good and not me!
So let's find out!
Cool.
*Inhale*
Maybe my channel is dying cuz I can't write it!
P E W D I E P I E
OH MY GOD
*Chuckles*
Well it looks like I'm not the only one with this problem!
PIE-DIE-PEW
Who the hell is PieDiePew?
Norwegian YouTuber, PieDiePew
He's my favorite, he's so funny
He's so good
Alright, let's just go into this
So here we get an interest over time graph
Pretty interesting, I would say, y'know. It's there. You don't really get the full picture unless you hit...
The whole graph. Lets start out here; in 2012, this is when I guess I started becoming more popular
I'm not exactly sure what date represents what
but i hit my peak
at 2014.
What happened in 2014?
I need to understand.
So... someone made a playlist. I guess I played games in 2014. No controversy, no nothing? Huh.
I'm actually in the same room. Nothing's changed. 5 years. Jesus Christ
When did I become the biggest channel?
In 2013, damn!
It's been a long time
In 2013, and then I peaked in 2014 and then it all just, it all just went down.
I think its interesting to note, at least for me,
'cause... anyone that came before me
almost every single channel that has been before me
has just disappeared, okay?
everyone that's been bigger than me,
they've all...they're all gone.
because of this fact, I've always just
looked at youtube, like, it could end at any day
like I just be ready to pack my dad-- bags at any day
i actually...oh wait, lemme see if can find that
sorry i...this video is gonna be one giant tangent
so I did a...
I think in 2012 I did a...
I did a presentation
Do not Google it for the love of God!
But I...I found a picture
(Laughs)
and I talked about, you know, doing let's-plays as a job
people didn't really know anything about it
at the time
look here I'm showing off my stats
be like, "Hey guys,
it's going pretty well!"
(Laughs)
There was one information that I really was interested by,
"Sick of boring lets plays?- I am your salvator!"
I found a presentation... where is it?
(Beautiful) faces of horror-- Okay, okay
So...how did I get to where I am? Full-time job, two videos every day, do something different, live myself into the game, luck.
So what happens in the future? I thought it was interesting how I kind of questioned  if i- it if was something stable or not.
With laws and regulations and copyright
I thought these things would hit...uh... quicker
I really... I was so unsure whether you would even be allowed to monetize the gameplay on youtube.
I think it's-- it's one of those things where people really
fought for... and to try and convince companies as well that it's benefitting for them.
Like these big publishers like EA, Bethesda, whatever.
They benefit from people playing their games and them understanding that has really had a huge impact on... Youtube and gaming.
I can easily see it going another way.
where gaming would just not be allowed on youtube. (glad it is tho)
and that has always been in the back of my head.
You know and now in the future 2019!
Nothing's really change it's Article 13 and all this stuff happening
I think this is where Wallstreet Journal happened
I think it happened in February
Cause it was literally on Valentine's day.
It was here!
So this is Wallstreet Journal, and then... babudababudaba!
Just been kind of stable for a long time...
and then JESUS CHRIST T-Series!
(Laughs)
But my favorite part of this graph is when I go,
"Hey guys, let's end the subscribe Pewdiepie meme like we shouldn't do this anymore."
OKAY!
Skydive graph
You know this is the kind of reports you want to see.
A full-on economic crash!
(Claps)
Thank you guys so much!
I can't wait to hit a 100 million subscribers in a couple of years.
"No one cares Felix"
FINE
You know what this is just America. What if like in Afghanistan I'm actually popular?
ZERO
What about Chad? WHAT ABOUT CHAD?
God dammit Chad!
So according to this this, uh, "State of America" I am most popular in the state of LO-VA (Iowa)
What the frick is that?
What the dumb name of a state, LOVA? (Iowa)
What do you love so much?
(Clap track)
Which country am I most popular in?
SWEDEN!
YEAH!!!
*inhales*
Thank you Sweden, very cool!
Too bad you're such a tiny, insignificant country.
Come on!
I nee- imagine if I was the biggest one in India
Oh my god
This is so sad
I am so oppressed
If I was born in any other country
Everything would be different
NORWAY
Come on!
What is this?
(Laughs)
Despite years of abuse, Norway's...
Norwegian bros are still here.
Thank you guys very
(Laughs)
New Zealand!
Australia!
Estonia...
What?
What is this?
Philippines is my second biggest country!
Damn!
PHILIPPINIAS bros!
Thank you!
(Laughs)
Okay, so what are the most search related terms
for Pewdiepie?
Pewdiepie, Swedish Youtuber
I don't understand why people
Make it all about me being Swedish
I never make my channel about being Swedish
Of course, T-Series, number two
So this is what most people have searched that's related to me
I think that's what it is.
And then the... third most related is my net worth.
Sorry, Marzia you're not as important
(Laughs)
Marzia comes, uh... Fourth
My net worth
(Typing) Pewdiepie net worth
So basically what this means is that most people that search Pewdiepie
Searched Pewdiepie net worth
So really, in reality what I should do is that I should title this video Pewdiepie net worth
And that will inevitably give me a lot of views based on search terms
According to this, my Net worth is twenty million...
Twenty million dollars
IT'S MORE.
I AM SORRY BUT IT'S A BIT MORE THAN THAT, GOOGLE
I don't know exactly how net worth is measured
But if it's based on how much on my bank account
Then I am sorry (Laughs)
You're coming a little short there, buddy
Ah, goddammit, it turns out I have already done the net worth...
I have already done the net worth meme
(Laughs)
"Marzia Bisognin - Italian internet personality"
Let's look at how Marzia is doing
Awww
Projection: That it might go up
Oh well, that's good.
Connecticut
Okay...
"Happy Wheels - Video game"
Guys
Happy wheels video game!
Jesus Christ Australia and New Zealand! Do you do anything but watch YouTubers?
Mr. Beast
Net Worth,
Net Wroth.
ME!
MR. BEAST.
PEWDIEPIE!
*chuckles*